Hey guys, welcome back to the King of Random.
Thanks for joining us today. Not too long ago,
we showed you how to build your very own air vortex cannon.
It's a fun toy that shoots out a ring of air that travels for a surprisingly long distance. Today,
we're going to take what we've already built and we're gonna see what happens if we scale them both up and  down. Now, when I
say we're gonna scale it down,
I mean we're going to get a lot smaller, and when I say we're gonna scale it up,
I mean we're going to get a lot
bigger. Let's start by making the tiny air cannon. For this tiny air cannon, pretty much all the supplies
we need are a tiny plastic cup and a regular balloon. Now,
we want to make a hole in the bottom of our cup that leaves a little bit of a border around it. It would probably
be pretty simple to cut that out with a knife,
but if you have a drill bit that makes nice big holes, why not use it?
With a hole cut in your cup, the next step is to cut your balloon.
We want to cut off the neck of the balloon
and then a little bit more, so we have mostly just the widest part of the balloon. Now, with our balloon cut,
we just need to stretch it over the open mouth of the cup.
That will actually hold itself on pretty well, but just to reinforce it,
I'm gonna use a little bit of tape to ensure that it doesn't go anywhere.
And believe it or not, just like that,
you have a miniature air cannon. Most balloons will have a little bit of a dimple on the back,
and so if you use that to grip, you can get a pretty good powerful shot out of your tiny cannon.
Of course, this is shooting out very small rings of completely clear air, so it's hard to see what's going on.
We're gonna set up a few different things to hopefully illustrate more clearly what's going on.
I have this hanging mylar decoration which moves very easily with just a little bit of air current,
so it's a great target to see if you're actually hitting it with these little rings of air.
First, let's try it out with the normal sized air bazooka.
There you go, our regular air bazooka works pretty well. You can see how much it moves the curtain.
We're going to be dealing with a much lower volume of air with our tiny one, but I bet it will still work.
I'm gonna try it from pretty up close just for the first couple shots, see how this works.
It moves, doesn't move nearly as much as a bigger one, but it definitely moves. All right,
I'm gonna try backing up from a little farther away, and see how it does.
Oh,
there it is.
Huh, it seems like it travels really fast too, like, like the instant after it snaps, making our mylar shake.
I want to try and find a way that I can see the air coming out of this,
so I'm going to start by just using a little bit of smoke from a match and see how well that works.
Well, there we go, getting some good smoke rings coming out.
You can probably see, instead of grabbing it and firing it out the way
I was, I'm just kind of tapping it on the back.
I think it fires so quickly that any smoke rings would just dissipate before you could see them.
I'll try one where I just shoot it out at full speed.
I think it's just gonna be too hard to see anything, but we'll try it.
Wow, yeah, like, there's a little bit of smoke that just disappeared almost immediately. It went way too fast.
You couldn't see the shape of it, so I think you're trying to make visible smoke,
it works best to just tap on the back of it. That seems to work out pretty well. Let's try that again.
There you go, it only takes a couple of minutes to make this tiny little air bazooka,
which has surprisingly good range and makes some really cool little rings if you add some smoke to it.
We now know how to make our tiny air bazooka. Now, let's move on to making our giant air bazooka.
This is something that has been done previously,
and I want to give a shout-out to Steve Spangler who's done something very similar on The Ellen Show. To start off,
we've got our trash can and a thick sheet of painter's plastic.
Let's place the mouth of our trash can face down on our painter's plastic, and then trace around it with a marker.
All right, we've got our circle drawn. Let's cut it out.
Before we attach it to the top,
let's cut a hole in the bottom of our trash can. Now, we want to cut a circle in the bottom of our bucket, leaving
a border of 2 or 3 inches. Our bucket full of tape has a bottom that's just the right size for our circle.
You can see that the bottom of our trash can is not perfectly leveled,
but I'm hoping it's level enough that it won't cause any problems. Unfortunately,
I don't have a hole saw this big, so I'm gonna be using a knife to cut this one.
That knife was having a hard time getting through the thicker parts of the plastic, so I'm upgrading to a jigsaw.
We now have a hole cut in the bottom of our trash can. Let's attach our painter's plastic to the top.
All right. Now, with the plastic attached on the back the way I've done it,
it's pulled tight and it's not attached to a bungee like we did with our small air bazooka.
But on this one, if you just hit the back like a drum, it will actually send out a wave of air from the front.
One of the other advantages of an air bazooka this size is that it makes really large rings.
So, let's try filling this one with smoke and see what kind of ring as we get out of it
There we go.
A very simply activated giant air cannon. However, I do have one more thing
I want to try. Using the exact same design we used on our regular-sized air cannon,
I went ahead and used a different trashcan and added the spring loaded back to it.
So, let's see what difference that makes
in our souped-up cannon.
Whoo, that was a way bigger ring.
That just moves the curtain so much. Yeah, you can really just see the ring flying through the air
and blasting the curtain out of its way.
I have here a batch of some of our colored smoke powder, and last time
I was trying to light some of this stuff off,
I had in a paper bowl, and the bowls kept lighting on fire. So this time,
I'm using a terracotta dish, pretty sure this is not going to burn.
Instead of lighting the smoke out here and trying to draw it into our smoke bazooka,
I'm going to try putting this entire terracotta dish
inside the trash can and light it up there, so all of the smoke that it produces will stay inside. We shouldn't lose any.
Let's start with just a pretty small amount.
I'm gonna light this off and as soon as it starts burning, I'm gonna start trying to fire this air bazooka.
There we go, getting some good smoke there.
I'm just gonna scoot it back a little bit farther.
Let's see what kind of air ring we get out of this.
Whoo!
And that just travels. Let's try that a second time.
I'm trying to hit the trees.
Three, two, one...
Nice.
There you have it, now in addition to the regular air bazooka,
you now also know how to make the tiny and the large air bazookas, which comes in the normal and the spring-loaded variety.
Thanks for joining us for this project today, and we'll see you in the next one. Talk to you then.
Least efficient method of raking leaves ever.
Hey guys,
I know there are so many great videos and great YouTubers out there that you could be watching instead of the King of Random.
So, I just want to say how grateful I am that you choose to watch us.
We're constantly doing everything in our power to bring you the best content we can make. So, truly, just want to say thanks.